à la question faut-il venir acheter la
nouvelle Apple watch Series 9 ma réponse
va être oui mais mais oui pourquoi déjà
on va prendre la base la base de la base
de la base si vous voulez acheter une
Apple watch soit vous en avez déjà une
soit vous n'en avez pas une si vous avez
déjà une Apple watch vous avez un iPhone
quelque part avec vous parce que bien
évidemment acheter une Apple watch si on
n pas un iPhone ça ne sert strictement à
rien si vous n'en avez jamais eu une et
que vous avez déjà un iPhone oui bien
évidemment vous pouvez acheter l'Apple
watch Series 9 qui est très bien qui a
un bon produit qui fait plein de choses
on en parle dans quelques instants je
vais tout vous détailler mais si vous
avez déjà une Apple watch récente une
serriies 8 une série 7 est-ce que ça
vaut le coup de venir acheter l'Apple
watch Series 9 pas nécessairement je
vous explique pourquoi parce que elle
est là l'Apple watch Series 9 et l'Apple
watch Series 9 elle est cool pour
plusieurs raisons la première raison
c'est que vous avez des nouveaux gestes
qui sont rendus possibles grâce au
nouveau cite plus les différents
capteurs c'est le S9 et qu'est-ce que
permet ce S9 et bien il permet d'avoir
des gestes vous allez faire un double
pincement comme ça et vous allez pouvoir
piloter votre mon monre
différemment c'est le Black Friday chez
Rino shield profiter des plus grosses
réductions de l'année qui vont jusqu'à
55 % sur certains accessoires puisquon
se parle ici d'Apple watch j'ai le
bracelet tressé de Rino shield qui est
super cool qui en plus de ça est
disponible en six coloris donc vraiment
vous avez de quoi faire il est résistant
il est confortable il est totalement
ajustable et il donne vraiment
l'impression d'avoir un bracelet tressé
fait sur mesure et surtout il se déforme
absolument pas et en plus de ça il est
moitié prix par rapport au bracelets
tressés qu'on peut retrouver chez Apple
et ces bracelets sont bien évidemment
compatibles avec les Apple watch 38 et
49 mm mais vous avez également plein
d'autres accessoires chez rinoield
puisqu'on se parle d'une Apple watch
vous avez probablement un iPhone qu'il
faut également venir protéger soit avec
les solid suit sur lesquelles vous avez
bien évidemment énormément de choix de
coloris ça c'est vachement cool vous
avez également la mod ENX dont le
Verseau est totalement interchangeable
et puis vous avez la clear qui est une
coque transparente qui ne jaunie
absolument pas en plus de ça vous avez
énormément de collaborations ici cher
sheld dans différents univers ça va être
One Piece ça va être la NBA il y en a un
peu tous les côtés c'est très bien et
vous pouvez même venir totalement vous
personnaliser vos propres coqu il existe
des protections d'écran antichoc avec
une nouvelle version antiumière bleue
disponible chez Rino shield et vous avez
également les classiques transparente
mat antiespion ou encore en verre trempé
plus des protections pour vos objectifs
photos à noter également que leurs
accessoires sont compatibles avec plus
d'une centaine de modèles de smartphon
dont les iPhone 15 les pixel 8 mais
également les Galaxy S23 voilà des
exemples de réduction vousz chez rinochi
pendant Black Friday jusqu'à 55 % de
remise directement sur vos coqus jusqu'à
35 % sur vos protection d'écran jusqu'à
25 % sur les accessoires et jusqu'à 20 %
sur les designs issus de licences
prestigieus c'est donc aujourd'hui le
meilleur moment pour venir vous équipé
en accessoir chez Rino shield une fois
de plus tous les liens sont en bas dans
la
description avant pour venir la piloter
bien évidemment on faisait quoi on
prenait sa montre on prenait son doigt
et on pilotait on appuyait on bougeit si
et ça ou alors vous avez la commande
vocale VOC vous appelez Siri et vous lu
dites fais-moi si fais-moi ça fais un
appel mais la musique arrête la musique
bref on peut venir le faire mais
aujourd'hui dans le truc un peu plus
imperceptible dans presque l'invisible
et bien on peut venir arrêter la musique
en faisant tac tac on peut venir lancer
la musique en faisant tac tac on peut
venir décrocher en appel en faisant tac
tac enfin je vous passe un peu
l'histoire vous avez compris le principe
ce truccl est vachement malin c'est très
intéressant pourquoi parce que je vous
fais une petite parenthèse pour moi
aujourd'hui on va chercher à se
débarrasser un peu de ces gros trucs là
on n est pas encore on voit qu'il y a
plein de solutions qui sont essayé la
Air peut-être la projection peut-être
bref ça devient un peu contraignant et
on cherche de nouvelles façons de venir
interagir avec nos objets connectés et
l'idée de venir le faire directement les
mains libres avec un petit tac tac ça
peut être super intéressant et Apple
commence à entrreouvrir la voix
directement alors attention c'est très
limité et ça marche mais des fois pas
toujours je vous fais un petit exemple
regardez je prends mon smartphone je
vais me mettre de la musique sur Spotify
allez hop là on fait attention les
droits d'auteur on se met les Guns
derrière je retrouve mes guns and rosis
directement ici là je fais tac tac je
suis en lecture il reconnaî il vous met
la petite icône vous voyez et là il l'a
passé en pause je refais un petit Tap
Tap hop il le reconnaît et là ça repart
directement donc quand on le fait comme
ça voyez Tap Tap hop là il l'a pas eu
tape tap là il l'a eu donc il y a des
fois ça marche il y a des fois ça marche
pas donc ça va dépendre quand même de
différentes choses déjà pour que ça
marche il faut que votre APPLE watch
soit éveillé si elle est en veille si
elle ne fonctionne pas si elle en
sommeil ça ne marchera pas il reconnaît
quand même plutôt bien il y a quelques
petites erreurs mais globalement
regardez hop là j'ai la main qui pend je
fais tape tap ça marche alors si
j'essaie avec le majeur est-ce que ça
marche tap tape voyez il l'a pris aussi
donc on vous parle de l'index mais pas
qu'avec l'index donc avec le majeur ça
fonctionne avec l'auriculaire ça reste
un sujet ah l'auriculaire il veut pas ah
si l'auriculaire il l'a pris aussi voyez
Tap Tap et alors on va tous les faire on
se fait avec l'anulaire tape tap avec
l'annulaire tape tape de l'annulaire il
le veut pas est-ce qu'il est un peu trop
loin bon on se refait l'index et ça
marche donc globalement l'idée elle est
pas mal ça c'est marrant pourquoi
pourquoi est-ce que ça m'intéresse et
pourquoi est-ce que ça m'interpelle et
bien tout simplement parce que imaginez
je suis avec mes airpods je suis je suis
en train de courir dans la rue ou j'en
sais rien je suis avec mespes j'ai un
truc dans les mains je suis en train de
faire des courses et que deux doigts de
de dispo et je veux prendre un appel je
vois qui m'appelle et bien j'ai qu'à
faire Tap Tap je peux décrocher je peux
pas forcément faire comme ça ou dire ok
répond bref c'est pas simple là je le
fais ça ça solutionne un petit peu
l'histoire j'ai un enfant dans les mains
je veux répondre à un appel une fois de
plus j'ai airpods je sais pas pourquoi
est-ce que j'aurai des airpods aux
oreilles avec un enfant dans les mains
CIT peut-être pour pas entendre l'écrit
peut-être aller savoir et bien je peux
le faire donc il y a plein d'usages qui
s'ouvrent ça va pas révolutionner
l'histoire ça va pas vraiment changer
l'histoire c'est un petit gadget une
petite fonctionnalité qui vient arriver
c'est une petite brique qui vient
s'installer ici directement sur votre
APPLE watch Series 9 et qui est rendu
possible grâce au SIP S9 donc c'est pas
mal est-ce que pour le coup ça vaut le
coup de changer d'une Apple watch series
8 ou une serriies 7 à une séries 9 la
réponse est clairement non donc ça c'est
le premier point et le deuxième point
qui est extrêmement intéressant sur
cette Apple Watch et bien c'est qu'Apple
est venu monter la luminosité encore
plus haute on peut passer jusqu'à 2000
nits alors le plus bas il vous le dis
c'est 1 l on descend au plus bas lorsque
vous êtes dans les salles d'obscur
prenne l'exemple du cinéma pourquoi pas
ça se tient mais on peut monter jusqu'à
2000 lit alors le problème attention ici
c'est que autant lorsque vous êtes en
plein soleil qu' a un cannard monstruux
dessus et que vous voyez pas grandchose
peut-être avec une génération précédente
quoique on voyez quand même plutôt pas
mal là vous allez extrêmement bien voir
moi je l'ai emmené en plein soleil je
peux vous assurer que je voyais vraiment
bien qu'il y avait aucun problème ici
donc ça c'était vraiment très très cool
le gros problème qu'on a lorsqu'on vient
pousser la luminosité un peu plus haute
qu'on met le curseur un peu plus haut et
bien c'est que l'autonomie drastiquement
elle va descendre et ça c'est souvent le
truc un petit peu relou avec les Apple
watch pourquoi je suis utilisateur
d'Apple watch depuis des années et je
vois que pour autant les puces évoluent
pour autant elles ont plus de capacité
de calcul et là c'est le cas elle est
beaucoup plus puissante beaucoup plus
performante mais l'autonomie reste la
même et je pense que c'est vraiment un
choix d'Apple de se dire nous on s'en
fout on veut une journée d'autonomie il
y a quelques générations en arrière ils
sont venus améliorer la vitesse de
charge de votre APPLE watch donc votre
APPLE watch elle se charge aujourd'hui
plus vite lorsque vous allez un peu bien
se laver avec mais lorsque vous allez
prendre une douche ou lorsque vous allez
faire je ne sais pas quoi et bien vous
pouvez la charger vous la reprenez une
petite demi-heure après vous êtes
peinard vous êtes parti pour 24 he sans
problème ce qui vous permet de venir
monitorer votre sommeil mais ça on en
parle dans quelques instants mais ça
veut donc dire que lorsquapple vient
améliorer la puissance ici de sa mone de
son CIP en passant sur la S9 on se dit
que normalement ça permet également
d'améliorer l'autonomie et bien en fait
non Apple ne cherche pas à améliorer
l'autonomie Apple cherche à améliorer
des fonctionnalités comme notamment
pousser luminosité un peu plus haute et
aller un peu plus loin en terme de
performance en se disant une journée
c'est le standard et une journée c'est
très bien moi j'aimerais bien Apple
qu'on emmène l'autonomie un peu plus
loin je suis d'accord ça se charge vite
c'est bien c'est pratique mais quand
même 2 jours 3 jours d'autonomie ça
serait pas du luxe autre usage qu'on
peut faire de son Apple watch ici c'est
l'ultra white band qu'on a dans sa monde
bien évidemment si par exemple et bien
je suis en train de perdre mon iPhone
qui est planqué je ne sais où qu' a
glissé dans le canapé ça m'est déjà
arrivé rigolez pas et bien j' trouve
très facilement avec ma montre c'est
quelque chose que je fais à assez
régulièrement et qui est pratique
attention donc bon si vous êtes un peu
têre en l'air ou si vous ne savez pas où
vous avez laissé votre smartphone ça
pourrait potentiellement vous sauver la
vie mais voyez au-delà de ces usages et
bien il y a pas grandchose de neuf la
vraie nouveauté elle se fait au niveau
de watchos10 qui est une superbe
expérience ici et c'est de toute façon
des gros points forts qui fait que on
vient acheter des produits de Apple
c'est-à-dire que l'expérience est
tellement bien pensé voyez alors ils
sont venus changer un peu leur
navigation qu'on avait avant c'est clair
c'est simple c'est lésible c'est in on a
toutes ces applications directement ici
je reviens à l'accueil ici je vais venir
retrouver un peu mes raccourcis
principaux mes applications i sur le
haut mes notifications ensuite sur le
bas et bien je vais retrouver aussi des
informations importantes et après ce qui
est cool c'est que je l' fait défiler
directement en faisant mon petit Tap Tap
Tap Tap avec mon doigt suivante suivante
voyez j'ai rendez-vous chez quoi faire
tout à l'heure Tap Tap donc une fois de
plus ça c'est quand même vachement bien
très pratique mais bon ça change pas
bien l'histoire watchos10 est une
excellente expérience donc si vous
regardez cette vidéo c'est que vous vous
dites ok est-ce que ça vaut le coup
d'aller sur la Watch Series 9 une fois
de plus si vous avez déjà un iPhone si
vous êtes dans l'écosystème Apple vous
savez à quel point ça fonctionne bien et
à quel point c'est vraiment pertinent
donc il y a pas de grosse nouveauté
d'autant plus que si vous avez déjà une
montre une génération précédente vous
avez pu faire la mise à jour normalement
tout ça vous le savez et ça change pas
vraiment grand-chose maintenant ce qui
rend l'Apple watch si unique bien
évidemment et bien c'est la force de
l'écosystème d'Apple c'est le fait
d'avoir un iPhone c'est le fait d'avoir
un iPad c'est le fait d'avoir un Mac par
exemple ici voyez un petit MacBook Pro
sur lequel je fais les montages c'est
tout ça qui fait que ça fonctionne
extrêmement bien que tout est
interconnecté
le fait également d'avoir vos airpods et
c'est la puissance de l'écosystème
d'Apple qui vient valoriser
individuellement chaque produit et c'est
là où certaines marques bien qu'elle
travaille vraiment à améliorer cette
partie làà sont pas totalement au niveau
d'Apple parce que il faut pas oublier un
point extrêmement important c'est qu'ici
Apple développe lui-même son matériel
son hardware et son software donc tout
est totalement optimisé et une fois de
plus ce qui permet à C Apple watch
d'offrir une expérience pas optimale
mais quasi optimale parce qu'elle a
quand même quelques petits Bill bien
qu'on soit sur une montre qui permette
de faire du sport c'est pas non plus une
montre de sport si on veut aujourd'hui
une montre totalement orientée sport on
va sur une Apple watch ultra première ou
deème génération à vous voir bien
évidemment mais ça fonctionne déjà
suffisamment bien et c'est quand même
relativement très précis après moi ce
qui m'intéresse réellement ici sur cet
Apple Watch et bien c'est tout ce qu'on
peut venir en faire en terme de données
de santé vous avez toujours les
applications qu'on connaissait et qu'on
a toujours ici c'est-à-dire votre
fréquence cardiaque donc là ça va me
faire un petit relevé il y a 9 minutes
GTA 70 BPM comme je tourne je suis un
peu plus speed à mon avis ça va monter
un petit peu plus 80 BPM ça va
globalement c'est pas fou fou c'est
intéressant également pour le suivi de
l'arythmie si vous avez un petit sujet
au niveau cardiaque et bien vous aurez
un vrai suivi au niveau de l'arythmie ça
c'est quand même vachement cool vous
avez toujours votre électrocardiogramme
votre petitte sé vous pouvez faire ici
avec une dérivation donc ça c'est quand
même pas mal votre taux d'oxygène dans
le sang le suivi du sommeil également le
suivi du cycle aussi également qui est
intéressant le cycle de menstruation
alors ça ça se fait au niveau de la
température une prise de température
lorsque vous dormez parce que lorsqu'on
bouge la journée on avir des fluctuation
de température donc là ce que vous êtes
au repos ces fluctuations elles
permettront de venir mesurer
effectivement et bien le cycle menstruel
dommage d'ailleurs que ce capteur de de
température ne puisse pas servir
aujourd'hui à autre chose mais bon
peut-être qu'un jour Apple développera
autre chose là-dessus et puis tous les
outils de sécurité qu'on va retrouver la
détection de chute la détection
d'accident le SOS si besoin ce qui en
fait globalement pour moi une des
meilleurs monde connectés qu'on retrouve
en complément d'un iPhone mais il y a
aussi de très belles solutions sur
Android mais une fois de plus si vous
vous posez la question ici aujourd'hui
et si vous regardez cette vidéo c'est
que vous avez probablement un iPhone si
vous n'en avez pas un vous voulez en
acheter un et vous vous demandez si
cette montre ferait l'affaire avec alors
oui pour moi elle fera très bien
l'affaire un tarif quand même
relativement élevé donc ça peut valoir
le coup de venir regarder les
générations précédentes pour se dire je
veux acheter une belle mononde connectée
je veux une Apple watch est-ce qu'une
série 8 ou une série 7 feront l'affaire
pour moi la réponse est oui et en plus
de ça la se reste aujourd'hui aussi une
très très belle alternative il y aura
moins de capteurs on en fera un petit
peu moins mais vous aurez quand même
watchos10 donc ça c'est quand même pas
négligeable donc posez-vous la question
de vous de vos usages est-ce que vous
avez besoin d'aller aussi loin au niveau
de la mesure de votre santé au niveau de
tous ces capteurs qui vont faire la
différence entre une série 8 une série 9
et une se peut-être pas pour moi la se
c'est quand même aujourd'hui peut-être
l'Apple watch à avoir mais si vous avez
un budget d'un peu moins de 500 balles
et je vous montre le tarif dans quelques
instants et que vous voulez acheter ce
qui se fait de mieux aujourd'hui en
terme d'Apple watch vous pouvez aller
les yeux fermés sur une Apple watch
Series 9 si maintenant vous avez un
budget un peu plus maîtrisé Série 7
série 8 ça fera parfaitement l'affaire
sans oublier la se que je recommande
énormément si on part sur un boîtier
aluminium ici avec un bracelet sport on
est à partir de 449 €. ça reste quand
même beaucoup d'argent alors attention
une fois de plus c'est pas un objet
qu'on va venir changer tous les ans tous
les 2 ans je vous le recommande pas donc
si vous avez une série 8 ou une série 7
conservez-les gardez-les il y a des
nouveautés mais le gap est pas non plus
énorme et puis ça ça change pas vraiment
la face du monde mais si vous avez un
modèle plus ancien ça peut valoir le
coupt à partir de 449 € quel que soit je
dirais votre bracelet après on peut bien
monter un peu plus avec un boîtier en
acier et inoxydable 849 € là c'est
vraiment le côté plus bijou qu'on va
venir rechercher puisque l'expérience
logicielle et les capteurs seront
exactement les mêmes et à vous de voir
une fois de plus pour venir trrouver
votre bonheur directement sur le site
d'Apple et si bien évidemment cette
montre connectée vous intéresse je vous
mets un lien juste en bas dans la
description donc pour moi l'Apple watch
Series 9 est une très jolie montre à
venir acheter soit parce que vous venez
d'arriver sur iOS et que vous voulez en
complément de votre smartphone une
mononde connecté soit parce que vous
avez un iPhone et que vous n'avez jamais
eu de mononde connecté et que vous avez
un budget un petit peu moins de 500
balles au quel cas l'appel watch Series
9 est cool et vous pouvez y aller une
fois de plus le lien est en bas dans
description mais si maintenant vous avez
une génération précédente 8e 7e
génération n'y allez pas ne changez pas
attendez peut-être plus tard en tout cas
les nouveautés qu'il y a là sont
intéressante mais c'est pas non plus la
grosse révolution néanmoins Apple ici
continue à nous proposer des choses
super intéressantes une évolution
génération après génération est-ce que
aujourd'hui moi cette Apple watch Series
9 me plaît la réponse est oui est-ce que
c'est comme dirait les Américains un
Game changer est-ce que ça change
vraiment les choses la réponse est NON
et puis bien évidemment je vous invite à
venir voir ma vidéo qui vous parle de
votre iPhone 15 pro max si vous en avez
pas peut-être que ça peut valoir le coup
de venir regarder bien évidemment la
vidéo est juste là allez voir parce que
c'est également un très joli smartphone
qui fait de super proposition et
notamment photo allez voir c'est par
ICI